welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and this is an in-depth breakdown
of Rick and Morty season 4 episode 7
promo dias ok the episode that started
as a Prometheus parody and ended as a
series darkest 911 iasts which is a
made-up word but all words I made up and
yesterday's Rick's planed after show we
joined voice of R actor Tara Strong here
I'm gonna go back through this episode
frame by frame to point out every
miserable information detail that make
this episode so shocking it grossed out
the animators who worked on it episode
opens with Rick and Morty already in
progress of what looks like an alien
xenomorph situation the title primordius
is a nod to prometheus the prequel to
the alien movies which showed how space
explores just can't help but touch wet
eggs and kiss facehuggers and fairness
those characters hadn't seen the alien
movies themselves when your fictional
universe has no good sci-fi to scare you
you wind up becoming a cautionary tale
yourself before they detach the
facehuggers they're carrying eggs
leaving us with a bit of mystery at the
top of episode as to what they were
doing making it super rewarding when
they flash back to reveal these face
huggers were in love and just trying to
start a family
morty gives us some solid reasoning to
create a pornhub account and rick
measures of civilizations progress by
whether or not they have an M&M store
holy you've got an M&M store now the
original host society were the pink pig
nose aliens who first showed up in
season 3's were literally conspiracy
episode with those kids playing in the
immortality field that was one of these
series darkest jokes up at that point
and then this race should begin last
episode is the vaping insell cult
follower who died inside flirty blood
man really this race has only ever had
terrible things happen to it the face
huggers bleed acid just like the
Xenomorphs and they explode out of their
bodies like the chest burster stage the
writers also cited Starro from the DC
comics which also reproduces asexually
and attaches to the face just lets this
relieved in the Xenomorphs morty worries
seems like a self-destructive lifecycle
is that gonna happen to us you feel an
egg in your stomach
no I'm glass half-full that sets at the
moment at the end of the episode when
they think they're gonna [ __ ] an egg
they get in some good jokes about media
creators well just cogs in the machine
you know makes you think I'm sure you'll
make this into a beautiful
film that your parents will pay for more
team a lot of the writers and animators
on the show probably new kids in art
school who looked too deeply into the
themes and their crappy projects that
really their rich parents funded jokes
on them you don't need to go to film
school to do that but yeah then they do
make sure the joke is on us specifically
with Rick's facehugger being a youtuber
who sucks so much and can't even get
brand deals selling vitamins by the way
this episode is sponsored but it's not
gonna be vitamins you'll see Rick's
rants on YouTube knock off you hosts
declare host you can see is a parody of
the folks who argue that different sexes
or races are biologically designed to
play certain roles in society which you
may be doing this too or this whatever
it is don't a me the alien who hates
Rick's videos tells Morty to fix him a
nod that all these face huggers knew
that Stephen Bruce were thing now the
[ __ ] they're gonna use to bring glory to
other planets like many things on Rick
and Morty has a distinctive dick shape
when they tow it behind them it's
content that spill out the tip initially
looked very spur me the shipbuilders
complain when Morty calls this off just
would have been nice to have heard this
sooner before we spent all day on it or
next time maybe put more thought into it
before a whole day okay well I'm sorry I
made you do your job for a good day you
look like you're all really busy before
I came in this is before Morty realizes
that the glories of life cycle is just
30 minutes so using that as a basis they
have spent an entire lifetime working on
this thing Morty tries to puppet his
face sucker mask using some mr. meeseeks
explanations on the floor and alien who
calls him out here is vocal cameo by
alan tudyk yeah well if we're free to
ask questions why haven't you blinked
for 20 minutes and why doesn't your
mouth move when you talk they escaped
and Rick ship which has its mic reverse
battery exposed always loved that sweet
continuity and they Mock the casually
high body count of Star Wars movies with
Morty back flipping into a Gunners seat
just like the one on the Millennium
Falcon and he hind like Gunners do in
the Star Wars movies
in the animation details in this part
goose super dark soldiers head gets
taken off showing the vertebra of a
spine they blow through a bridge killing
a ton of civilians including one that
sticks to the windshield
during this Rick opens up about his
mental health I'm sorry if I've been
taking it out on you
no I get it you got a lot on your plate
amigo I just wish you'd open up to me
more about it sometimes you know I'm
your partner thanks Morty I mean that
thank you
sometimes I get a little in my head you
know hey none of this is a valid excuse
to slaughter a race of people it's the
writers joking about how [ __ ] tend
to justify their cruelty and abuse by
shrugging oh sorry I'm just going
through some stuff yeah your feelings
just be decent summer does the same
thing at the end of the episode summer
why'd you let these things stay on us
for so long I was working with a lot
just let me listen to the podcast next
time Rick uses a huge-ass laser to take
down two tiny ships please replace the
way bigger than necessary melting a
building behind them and then when we
cut back to Rick he is briefly wearing a
seat belt which Rick never does either
he briefly feels vulnerable after
opening up or it's an animation
oversight they approached Twin Towers
resembling the World Trade Center towers
and swerve past saying that a 9/11
reference would be low-hanging fruit and
they're above that to be clear it is not
the value of life that makes them swerve
it's like a humorous snobbery over
making a cheap joke which is kind of
worse which is why immediately after
this they bomb a Pearl Harbor Pearl
Harbor on the other hand yeah I think
that's in bounds
notice of the animators recreated rows
of battleships and cruisers and palm
trees and you could see poor little
sailors on these ships getting blown to
hell and that wasn't bad enough
Rick and Morty blast out of there right
over first responders just trying to
free civilians from the rubble all of
them Dead's Oh one of them just has is
severed bottom Ave sticking up in the
air yeah I think about that every time
the Star Wars sequel trilogy hyperspeed
skips close to a planet's surface none
of your ears are good people especially
the scrappy ones because you cannot
spell scrappy without the letter S which
stands for sucks we know what heroes I
find most charming and relatable or the
ones that are scrappy and self-made kind
of like a good PC customized just the
way you want it well thanks to omae's
for sponsoring this video enter for your
chance to win $20,000 to build your
ultimate dream PC while supporting a
great charity by going to omae's comm
slash rockstars and using the code
rockstars
5450 additional entries Oh mazes model
democratizes traditional oxygen giving
by offering everyone the chance to have
a once-in-a-lifetime experience that
also benefits a charity through the Oh
maze platform people from more than 180
countries have made donations that
support over 350 charities driving
awareness for the charities work and
raising more money than traditional
methods
they've given over a hundred thirty
million dollars to charity and their
goal is to raise a billion dollars for
charity in a single year on omae's you
can enter to win a Tesla play Dungeons &
Dragons with Joe Manganiello or have a
virtual coffee date with the cast of The
Office while supporting charities like
make-a-wish and the Boys and Girls Club
omae's is offering you the chance to win
an ultimate dream PC whether it's for
gaming film editing graphic design or
whatever you like taxes and shipping are
included and even better every donation
benefits a great cause
gamers outreach a charity that does
awesome work with a gaming community to
provide recreation to children and
hospitals all you got to do is go to
omae's comm slash rockstars and enter
for your chance to win use the code
rockstars 5450 additional entries back
at home Rick blames the Saudis for 9/11
another example of his charged middle
east few political stances which we saw
back in the Vindicator episode in season
3 if anything the trunk version of me is
probably
supportive of Israel he wants what's
best for it and hey man I'm not touching
this you do you Jerry reveals that he's
begun beekeeping with a jar of Jerry's
own honey is a nod to Newman's Own Paul
Newman's charity food brand i love how
after defending themself Gary moves out
to the conversation about summer just
continued stupid enjoys breakfast and
live his life Morty and Rick returning
it's summer and notice they brought
their pancake breakfast to go because as
we know from the first Citadel of Rick's
episode Rick hates mushy pancakes I hate
to get all Andy Rooney about it but I
think we all like fluffy just to cake
with syrup on top morning feels bad
about their destruction Rick calls back
past violent episodes do you think we
never go back to a place we've already
been you know how many adventures we
could get out of purge planet Morty Keir
world
I don't sequel it's called integrity
look who's purging now ended with a
similar supersuit bloody massacre and
Morty night run wrecks gear world with
similar carnage beer bottle spill out of
Rick's car as always and Rick uses his
Rick pewter to suit up the two of them
and anime armor inspired by Gundam Wing
and Voltron Ronin they clean up and
Rick's ship drills the freaking hole in
the ground is similar to the high
collateral damage world engine in mana
steel throughout all this morning Rick
are still unaffected by the violence
they've caused I know my wrists are
killing me flame throwers next time for
sure they find summer who is actually
the empress of this planet some some
come with us if you want to live a
little terminator reference there notice
that her minions have hats with a peace
sign showing how she became ruler on
message of glory so is peace in prison
Morty sings a tune nobody knows the
trouble I've seen you know that song
Rick he's singing the American slave
spiritual there's also sing by Zazu and
The Lion King
[Music]
summer reveals what led to this
facehugger situation a flashback shows
the three of them listening to a podcast
yeah I'm talking about summoning guard
cool for three episodes summer yeah
they're joking about the podcast serial
in which the host Sarah Cain egg was
made fun of for forming a weird
fascination with the subject Adnan Syed
and Kat saying she was gonna call him in
prison in the next episode but then like
pushing it off it tells them to pretend
podcasting isn't boring which might be a
nod to Dan Harmon's recent departure
from hosting the Harding town podcast
they crash land on the asteroid like the
derelict spacecraft in Alien movies and
morning Rick stupidly tampered with the
wet eggs while summers dumb tooth
picking stabs of facehuggers in the eye
she hears the glories a life cycle but
tells them to do more than reproduce
opening their culture to immediate
strides use again they only live for 30
minutes so a lot gets done in that time
dan harmon himself saying this patriotic
glory so song over imagery including
glory Zoe's writing tandem bikes and
flying kites the school is decorated
with facehugger paper art it on the
ceiling students have thrown up pencils
and gum there's also a knife up there it
looks like Morty and Rick's facehuggers
Steve and Bruce professed their love she
took you away from me I feel the same
way yeah this is kind of the show
hinting at a gross relationship between
Morty and his grandfather since yeah it
is their voices but technically it's the
facehuggers who are in love and yeah
Justin roiland assuming both voices
anyway also when summer finishes her
story they say hey wait a second how did
you know that last part you weren't
there for that I had to fill in some
gaps everyone around the office knew
about Stephen Bruce so yeah even though
Steve and Bruce were definitely in a
relationship and definitely gathering
eggs for a family the more erotic parts
of the story might have just been
unreliable narrator summers
embellishment Reagan Morty faced a
council of blurs Oh similar to the
council of ricks Ricky's as Morty's
harmonica tuned to burst the glorious
makes Morty feel a bit bad
they returned home realized they've
learned nothing and they sit down to
watch an interdimensional cable the
second episode in a row that ends like
this
so watch some interdimensional cable but
this time we do get they think they're
gonna [ __ ] an egg Morty full circle from
the pilot full circle it's a joke about
how back in the pilot Morty had to show
the mega seed up is but now something
huge is coming out but instead they've
just been shown before a nod to get
schwifty [ __ ] on the floor time to get
swifty yeah the both squared seams shows
summer is horny friend Trish checking
out Jerry's BK bean summer oh really
this is kind of a nod to American Beauty
in which cancelled Spacey is a loser dad
in a midlife crisis finally begins
standing up for himself and picking up
hobbies fantasizing about his daughters
teenage girlfriend who at the end of the
movie does come on to him also in the
backyard you can see the grassy mounds
where Rick and Morty buried their own
bodies back in season one the animators
usually keep these graves visible every
time we get an angle of this part of the
property but uh I do hit one last
reminder to check out yesterday's Rick's
planed episode to see us break down the
darker elements of this episode with
Tara Strong super fun episode one of the
first times in a while I was
legitimately starstruck and join our
official discord server by becoming a
patron at patreon.com slash new rock
stars follow me on Instagram and Twitter
I da vas probably new rock stars
subscribe to this channel for more Rick
& Morty breakdowns thanks for watching
and fingers crossed YouTube bots don't
hear me say 9/11 and even monetize this
[Music]